now at 11 we are bringing awareness to a
topic that can be hard to discuss or
even acknowledge but for victims
domestic violence is their life madison
kimbrough spoke with safeness a local
non-profit that says they're seeing
close to 40 thousand victims this year
in clark county a much higher amount
than years before she joins us live
tonight madison
a safe nest along with metro has seen a
change in numbers a big change when it
comes to domestic violence whether it be
in homicide related deaths or more
victims coming forward
our homicide rate is
skyrocketing i'm afraid to say and a
good portion of our homicides are
domestic related october is domestic
violence awareness month and for many
it's seen as a violence among couples
but that isn't always the case according
to the nonprofit advocacy group safe
nest 40 percent of domestic violence
cases don't even fall under the intimate
partner umbrella and with so many
uncontrollable elements happening around
us in the world often abusers will hone
in on what they feel they can control
not only did the rates of domestic
violence go up but the depth and the
literal number of punches the amount of
psychological abuse the number of curse
words for example all of these things
exponentially raised within households
because we have an incredibly stressed
out community for the victims getting
help isn't the easiest but metro says
coming forward is the best step you can
take in seeking justice it's essential
that they participate in the court
process because
these are criminal cases and in order to
move forward we need to have witnesses
and evidence
now the safe nest crisis hotline is up
on your screen the nonprofit is hosting
a run for hope 5k one mile event that's
going to be in honor of survivors
victims and loved ones that's on
saturday october 16. reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now